voir environ 2500 en fonction des
critères et des moments voire à 3000
c'est donc une certaine mise en
perspective historique que nous
attendons de cette audition puisque vous
étiez au manettes à une époque où le
problème des pénuries de médicaments
n'était pas encore devenu en France un
enjeu aussi prévenant que maintenant et
semblait réservé aux pays plutôt du Sud
vous avez exercer les fonctions de
ministre de la santé il y a suffisamment
longtemps pour ne pas avoir été mêlés à
des décisions en lien avec la situation
actuelle et c'est ce recul qui nous
intéresse et le regard forcément avisé
qui vous portez sur cette situation
auditionner en septembre 2020 par la
commission d'enquête du Sénat sur la
gestion de la crise de la covid vous
aviez posé comme principe je vous cite
qu'aucune pandémie ne ressemble à une
autre nous en avons constaté l'effet
très récemment vous poursuiviez il faut
donc se méfier comme de l'apaise des
leçons du passé et des fameux retours
d'expérience dont nous sommes si fr
les plans de lutte imaginaient à froid
sont des brodequins d'acier qui
contraignent la décision politique nous
avons besoin d'outils nous n'avons pas
besoin de procédure mais précisément le
phénomène qui donne à cette commission
d'enquête sa raison d'être à savoir le
caractère désormais structurel des
ruptures de stock et des tensions
d'approvisionnement car il y a rupture
il y a tension en médicaments et d'un
tout ordre que les situations d'urgence
et de crises que sont les périodes de
pandémie hn- ou covid même si nous
avions nous avons connu cet hiver une
accusation suite à la dans un contexte
de triple épidémie covid grippe et VRS
si les menaces aux exceptionnelles de
prennent jamais la forme que l'on attend
il est question ici de rechercher des
solutions pérennes à un problème pérenne
celui de la provisionnement du marché
français entend normal hors période de
crise sanitaire même si évidemment il
prend un tour cruel lors des des moments
critiques il s'agit donc bien de
prévenir plutôt que de réagir et encore
moins cherché à guérir dans l'urgence et
il nous est précieux de bénéficier de
votre expérience celle d'un temps où le
problème dont nous sommes saisis
n'existait pas même si les causes
profondes étaient peut-être et même
certainement déjà à l'oeuvre et vous
nous direz d'ailleurs dans quelle mesure
il ne s'agit donc en aucun cas où l'avez
compris de vous demander des comptes sur
vos actions passées ni de juger
d'ailleurs vos successeurs mais
d'échanger avec vous pour mieux
comprendre ce qui a pu changer sur le
long terme puisque nous sommes vraiment
au stade du long terme dans le circuit
du médicament pour expliquer les
difficultés actuelles je vais
immédiatement donc vous cédez la parole
pour un bref propos introductif puis
madame Laurence Cohen rapportera de
notre commission d'enquête vous posera
une première série de questions je
précise également que cette audition est
diffusée en direct sur le site internet
du Sénat et qu'elle fera l'objet d'un
compte-rendu publié avant de vous donner
la parole je vous rappelle qu'un faux
témoignage devant notre commission
d'enquête et passible des peines prévues
aux articles 434 13 434-14 et 434-15 du
code pénal je vous invite madame la
ministre a prêté serment de dire toutes
les vérités rien que la vérité en levant
la main droite et en disant je le jures
je vous remercie beaucoup vous avez la
parole madame la ministre
madame la présidente Madame la
rapporteur mesdames sénatrices messieurs
les sénateurs
Mesdames et Messieurs les fonctionnaires
du Sénat je me prête bien volontiers à
l'exercice de l'audition devant une
commission d'enquête